mais on aurait thien ah koon maire du
tampon conseiller départemental change
et du développement durable au conseil
départemental
je suis maire depuis 1983 je suis le
doyen des maires de la rue
sommes sur le canton benseke la fédé 4
c'était l'endroit où je suis né
j'ai vécu par louis nos planteurs noces
éleveurs je connais leurs conditions de
vie et les tares de leur situation
sociale et économique
j'en ai fait un challenge pour ici est
d'aider notre population les sortir de
leur pauvreté
alors sommes sur deux volets essentiels
premièrement les oda réunion si nous la
patronne des hauts de la réunion c'est
nous poêler au volcan il faut passer par
chez nous nous recevons chaque année en
moyenne 400 mille visiteurs nous
espérons avec cilaos n'est pas miss de
la plaine des cafres demain fin d'une
plateforme touristique qui permettra à
de nombreux réunionnais de ne plus être
catiches de l'amérique se trouve au toit
ne met de pouvoir respirer l'air et
pouvoir avoir des loisirs de qualité si
pour cette raison que nous voulons unir
nos efforts pour faire de la place des
palmistes de silence et de la
plaine-des-cafres une plateforme
touristique exceptionnel et dans ce
schéma nous mettons en place deux choses
ap temps qu'on a avancé le parc du
volcan qui est déjà des cas c'est depuis
30 ans pour une réalisation que nous
allons concrétiser et qui sera un enjeu
considérable pour créer globalement
surprenait caf en créant 300 emplois
directs et en multipliant par trois
effets induits par la présence d'un parc
de loisirs arriver à créer 900 emplois
au total est travaillé avec 6 losc aidés
en nous et puis avec apple est promise
pour que tout ça provoque un grand
engouement touristique permettant aux
touristes internationaux de venir chez
nous
la deuxième chose c'est le projet du
belvédère de grand bassin où nous allons
mettre en place avant la fin de l'année
tous les dispositifs d démarrage du
chantier pour eux la création d'un
téléphérique et d'un belvédère et avec
les équipes en très important et toxique
en parlant exceptionnelle qui listera
qu'à la réunion et pas l'os crânien un
grand projet c'est celui du
développement durable nous travaillons
sur des projets tels que subit de la
géothermie mais celui qui est le plus
concret c'est que ce barrage que vous
voyez derrière nous et en a aujourd'hui
700 mille mètres cubes de stockage
demain où sera à 1 million 400 mille
mètres cubes de stockage et nous
pourrons utiliser des turbines
hydroélectriques qui vont produire de
l'énergie électrique et contribuer à
faire en ce sens que la réunion dans le
cadre de son action permettent de
fournir une énergie capables de
rentabiliser les investissements publics
communaux et en même temps créer des
emplois et en même temps réduire
l'importation du charbon pour produire
de l'électricité à la réunion donc notre
contribution pour le développement
durable c'est celui de créer de
l'énergie hydroélectrique deuxièmement
c'est de faire en sorte que la le
développement de notre notre site ici
courrier et quatre tenues collinaires
seront recouverts de panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques
c'est dans ces conditions là que nous
disons que aujourd'hui les enjeux du
développement dans les hauts de la
réunion sont exceptionnelles puisque
n'avons pas d'industrie nous nous
tournons vers la nature et la nature
c'est l'ami à demain avec leurs chambres
thématiques
l'udps et partons nous continuer à
veiller sur tous les espaces forestiers
de la nature l'écologie le développement
durable la biodiversité à l'île de la
réunion si on rate raison que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens
qui ce qui s'impose aux que la réussite
de l'écologie soit pour notre île un
exemple